[Music] This movie is about something that we don't really
know yet, and we're surrounded by movies
in this room that I'm in and
this is the best we can do
and I'm the one who's sitting here who
has to come up with it. So let's show my sandwich
this is the sandwich I'm having for lunch
and it's a it's a chicken, buffalo chicken
sandwich with a lot of chips, I like chips. I always have
a pickle. I was halfway through the sandwich
when I was asked to participate in this
project that we're working on, I don't know what we're doing
I think you you
we have to do something, he drags his
feet, he's always talking about
he's always making it about him but it's reallyabout us, right?  And he's always doing this thing
with his his sandwiches it's like he has a like athing, he's always like to check out my sandwich it
always degrades down to like his sandwiches and I
don't you know I don't think that makes for good
like good documentary footage, you know? Like
we need to have something something deeper, you know, something more profound.
I want to talkabout my sandwich which is the same every day
it makes me happy and this is where my life is [laughs]
This is the highlight of my day, is my sandwich
I mean it's more like a distraction from what we need to be doing which is making this
film I mean he is the head of the film department, right,
he's surrounded by films of all different
qualities and calibers and genres and you ask
like hey can we try this one thing, right?And it
just falls apart, he puts the blame, blames it on me, you know, which I think is unfair
I try, I try,but Lupe is a multi-platinum winning artist
uh, he's a genius and, you know, I
count on him for the ideas and then I
I'm a worker bee you know and yeah I run the
film office and uh I do take inordinate pleasure
in my lunch and my sandwich which I mentioned
earlier one thing I'd like to clear up though